Yeah,
I mean South Africa is a very
interesting case right now because I
think I'm
politically what's happening is in the
next couple and the next fortnight
actually a new African National Congress
president will be elected and whoever
becomes president of the ANC effective,
he becomes president of the country
because they get sort of 65 percent of
the vote in any national election.
And the front runner at the moment is
this,
the Sky Jacob Zuma,
who was deputy president and then got
fired because he's,
um,
he was charged with both rape and
corruption.
He got acquitted on the rape charge that
said the most horrific,
um,
ms dot dennis stick things during the
trial and the corruption charges being
sort of put off and put off and put off
in these something,
you know,
some funny business going on there.
But the reason he is interesting is,
um,
he has massive popular support among
low,
low class,
um,
South Africans who I think feel that,
you know,
it's been too long now since 94 and
they're not seeing the kind of practical
material changes in their lives and you
know,
houses running water,
electricity.
And so there's a kind of,
um,
radicalism that's sort of um,
being fostered at that level.
And for some reason Zuma has captured
the imagination of these people and he
is not being seen as the antidote to.
I'm the kind of politicians like in
Becky who's the current president or a
lot of the extremely wealthy,
um,
black businessmen like Tokyo,
six waller who's a,
basically a mining magnets.
So I think it's a,
what's coming to hid non South Africa is
this thing of what happened is a lot of
the wealth was just sort of transferred
from this tranche of elite whites to
elite blacks and the people on the
ground.
So nothing changed in their lives.
And so there's a,
there's a kind of a backlash against
that.
And so it's playing out more along class
lines now than it is along race lines.
Racist still used as a galvanizing
factor politically.
So,
um,
you know,
Zuma will often use whites as scapegoats
to sort of get people
riled up.
But really it's an issue of,
um,
feeling like not enough has happened to
kind of
change the economics of the country in a
way that benefits ordinary South
Africans that makes him sound like I'm a
much better person than he is.
I mean,
I think this is one of the things that
worries me a lot at the moment.
It's like watching a train smash about
to happen.
Um,
and the,
the global community doesn't really seem
to see how terrible it would be if he
becomes president.
I mean,
there's nothing you can do,
but I think if he became president,
South Africa would go the way of
Zimbabwe within five to 10 years.
I think he would do a land grab.
I think he would have nationalized all
sorts of things.
But I think he's a leader who has
absolutely no.
Um,
no qualms about,
um,
you know,
doing what is best for him and um,
scared.
Hmm.